I've come to realize wow I'm the human
version of my favorite thesis which is
whoever is closest to the consumer wins
[Music]
the Internet is where our lives will be
there's a good chance a lot of the
youngsters in here will literally sit in
a pod eight hours a day and live their
lives it's real and so I think we need
to really wrap our heads around what
that means and so and I also think we
need to wrap our heads around how fast I
think this is actually gonna happen
[Music]
I think about Mariano Rivera Rivera a
lot he's a baseball pitcher he's all
time and he's all time
and he had one pitch and I really think
that's who I am
I think I'm stunningly one-dimensional
but I'm so deep in this one thing that
it's gonna be able to bring all of you
value which is I'm really intuitive
about consumer attention whether that's
in a b2b environment whether that's
gonna be to see environment basically
all I ever do it comes natural to me
it's my interest it's what I spend my
time on it's actually how I see the
world like I actually see the world
through how do you make the decisions
that you make why do you make them to
the jokes about politics to why he's
wearing that shirt or why you're wearing
your beanie like the why we use fashion
to communicate you know our facial Kate
like every single thing to me is
communication and it really matters
because this is probably the moment that
attention is being most disrupted
probably since the printing press what
Guinness beer company did by creating
the Guinness Book of World Records they
created the Guinness Book of World
Records so people at pubs in the early
1900's would talk about silly things
like who's the tallest reference the
Guinness Book of World Records which
would reinforce the brand Guinness and
make them order Guinness at a pub the
reason you go to a three-star Michelin
restaurant or resort is because the
Michelin tire company 100 years ago
wanted people in France in London to
drive outside of the main city and use
their gas stations and use their tires
up so they started reviewing restaurants
in the countryside under the Michelin
Guide very positively to inspire the
wealth to leave for the weekend media as
advertising I think the old world of
Guinness and Michelin is actually the
new world if you don't live in a
cellphone mobile device world in your
mind and the
sonot fifty percent of the time spent on
a mobile device is spent on a social
network the mobile device is the most
important thing in our lives and it
grows every day and this is 50 percent
overall it's not 50 percent of 19 year
olds this is net 50 if you are not
advertising on and properly on Facebook
and Instagram you're you're becoming
irrelevant by the second if you go to
the private schools in Greenwich
Connecticut when you get your birth year
you're licensed here and now what's
interesting is it's going younger your
expectation is that your parents don't
buy you a BMW or Mercedes your
expectation is that your parents give
you unlimited uber the birthday present
of choice for a 16 year old girl in
Greenwich Connecticut is not a cherry
red convertible it is unlimited uber and
the parents would rather have it because
it's the perception of safety
I couldn't have sold a single person on
this ten years ago ten years from today
fourteen-year-old girls are gonna go
into strangers cars on a nightly basis
and that's what the parents want to
happen yeah you could have never sold
that I've come to realize wow I'm the
human version of my favorite thesis
which is whoever is closest to the
consumer wins
that's why Amazon's winning I think one
of the most fascinating things in the
world is the real celebrities are not as
famous as the influencers anymore and
it's not even close by the way a real
celebrity is not as famous as an
influencer on Instagram they're just not
they're just not like you can see it in
every metric that you want logan paul
sells way more merchandise than any a
list celebrity and it's not even close
way more people watch YouTube vlogs and
follow Instagram celebrity I mean go
look at the numbers celebrities made a
huge mistake because they were famous
and they were slow to Instagram they
were embarrassed to go to Instagram and
have a small following count so they
never jumped in and they just let all
the people get bigger and bigger and
bigger it was ego content that's
bringing people potentially value
escapism entertainment information is
very different than buy my car buy my
wine buy my blouse it's just literally
positioning Grey Goose at Wine Library
is $32 a bottle feels one way Grey Goose
at lava at a table feels a totally
different way miss five hundred bucks
its context car dealerships are super
interesting to me because I'm fascinated
by what I call expiring employees
meaning if there's somebody sitting in a
car dealership waiting for a human being
to come in they could be doing something
so for me what they could be doing is
searching a ten-mile radius on Twitter
somebody will tweet that they pop their
tire and they're on the side of the road
in theory that sales person could jump
into one of your cars drive over change
the tire and drive them to work which
then would create word-of-mouth buy at
maybe the local news would pick up on it
and now you're building brand awareness
there's so much smart [ __ ] you can do
once you make the switch creative as the
variable of success once you make the
switch that this is the only world now
all of a sudden you do the homework now
all of a sudden you spend the 15 hours
reading on Google how do I create a
filter how do we run out some Facebook
how do you sell cuff link how do you
sell cars on Facebook enter get much
informations there for free
unlimited
[Music]
go to Spotify maybe even Apple music
right now if my team can move fast
before we post this on the podcast open
Spotify search Monday to Monday tio
Monday scroll all the way to the bottom
playlists follow that playlist and get
straight fire every Monday morning good
still off the high of that moment oh
yeah are you trying to figure out how to
make that more successful yeah let's go
let's go a different route Shane I'm
gonna fly you to New York City to
vaynermedia and you're gonna spend a day
with me and my team and we'll show you
good I'm glad we finally made it happen
have you been well what's your Instagram
while you're signing I'll look at your
Instagram a little bit oh I'm just
followed your brother Shane ex 1975 help
you within my time I know you're gonna
be spending time with the team observing
yeah but you obviously you want to build
your personal brand up right yeah and so
ultimately to do more books and more
speaking and make a living that way yeah
I love it
Shane helped me understand what are you
when you said it was your side hustle
now or do you have a side job do you
have an actual job right now and this is
still your side also yeah I figured yeah
I remember I remember still so how much
time a day does that take up and so how
much time are you able to work on your
brand and your side hustle you know for
a couple hours before work I said
they're in you know what are you doing
reap replying responding to people's
people commenting and so forth on
Facebook and on Instagram where he's
young but you're not getting too much
engagement on you're not getting a lot
of comments on your posts right right so
yeah you don't it's not taking up a lot
of time for you too
and back because there's not a lot
coming in right right so then what are
you are you seeking out conversations
then when you say in the morning you're
spending time oh are you leaving
comments watching you're watching your
videos understood which is okay which is
okay
have you started going into other
people's content and becoming a bigger
part of the community I believe that if
you leave your two cents and let's call
this the 18 cent strategy let's make it
up right here in a spot I want you to
start deploying the 18 cent strategy
you're gonna drop a dollar eighty a day
two cents at a time nine top posts times
ten different hashtags every day and
that will massively build up your
audience you're gonna leave a dollar
eighty in karma a dollar eighty in
community a dollar eighty in your
thoughts
you're not gonna spam yeah I see people
in my account all the time follow me
follow me you're not gonna spam yeah
you're gonna be part of the gratitude
thankful the present choose happiness
positivity community
Shane everybody wants to talk yeah the
way to win is to listen and then
contribute everybody wants to talk
everybody wants to put a picture of
themselves like you looking cool running
yeah but I looked at your social and
just like 99% of people watching
nobody's listening yet that's okay
that's not discouraging to me nobody
listened to me at first either let me
say it one more time for over a year
nobody watched my goddamn shows on one
the way to be discovered is to either
put out great content have one great
piece of content go viral and then
everybody discovers you or the way I
like it
become part of the community you will
pick up three to four followers a day
that are meaningful that means you'll
get a hundred meaningful people in a
month that means you'll put out a piece
of content and if one of them is special
that's it's just amazing how it works
but this will keep you fresh you know
what's also great about it the hidden
great part of this you're gonna get
exposure you're gonna get some followers
you're gonna contribute and be a great
community member but you're also gonna
learn
because you're gonna watch and consume
ninety pieces of content that are doing
well on Instagram which is then going to
inspire and help you strategize the
content that you yourself are gonna put
out on Instagram that's a good use of
three hours a day in the morning during
your lunch break while all the dishes
are drying when you get home
tried-and-true everyday gratitude
empathy kindness striving motivation
motivational Monday you pick the
hashtags they're unlimited yeah and they
all have a top name let's do one
together and say nothing Trump's the
work you can be here for a whole week a
whole day you can spend your life with
me what's that old adage right show it
show a horse how to drink the water
right or show if somebody had a fish
right they never have come here
they'll never have a day in life that
bottom line is instead of giving you
some fish to eat right now I'm gonna
teach an official in the life I want you
to do that 89 more times today I mean
dead serious yeah I'm glad you're here
man yeah there's a really good moment
for me yeah thank you very much can I be
a hundred percent that's a good poster
right on it's a car so let me give you a
piece of choice gather as much attention
as you can as much as you can because
you're gonna trade on that to your point
no matter what comes out of your guys
collective mouth we're gonna start a
beverage business we're gonna start
we're gonna create our own we're gonna
create our own label we're gonna we're
gonna start a we want a beats by dre
moment it's gonna be that [ __ ] rat ass
fly thing like whatever the [ __ ] you
guys are gonna say all of it is gonna
trade on one currency attention the [ __ ]
am i doing I'm just gathering so much
attention and then I get to deploy it
Mike a Swiss collab outsold future in
the weekend it makes no [ __ ] sense
like this much sense because I'm more
attention that people realize and my
attentions deep those guys have way more
attention than I do but it's scattered
on other things and there isn't that's
it there's connection I'd be unfair but
like that's right what I want for you
and anybody else in your position this
young this much talent this kind of
collective crew you know to me it's like
it's why I always thought Drake was
playing it right in what here's what's
smart about what Drake did and I have no
idea if this is what they thought I just
don't know but the volume of projects
that he put out speaks to my thesis
which is when you're hot [ __ ] like
when you've got the best hand [ __ ]
keep playing it I think the other thing
that I'm obsessed with is who you
collaborate with Louis Vuitton and Under
Armour and Reebok and everybody else
they're all in deep [ __ ] [ __ ] my man
that game was over I'm glad your
reaction there
guys guys they're all dead here's what
that means instead of worrying about
that right now
go [ __ ] into attention-grabbing pop up
24 months you'll get pieces of equity in
Nautica [ __ ] a deal just a little more
patience right now at the time that it's
the hardest because you've been [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] and now you're here but
you're here do you know what I mean
and what's crazy is right now this is
why everybody this is why most people
don't win this is the time that you go
even more [ __ ] eating not the reverse
and it's so countercultural because you
guys well talking about this day for
[ __ ] every day for the last 2000 days
in a row and now you're here and you
think you're here and it's like no no no
and that's what I did
I [ __ ] invested in Facebook Twitter
Boober everything I was here I did it
and I decided to build a client service
agency go into clients and eat [ __ ] in
the prime of my career so I'm giving you
advice I took and now I'm really here
and I'm still not really you know what
I'm like the longer you can hold your
breath you win I'll give some love I'll
get some followers
[Music]
[Music]
long day of meetings here in
headquarters I got to tell you this
because my son I he'll kill me if I
don't right so I sent him this okay
because I've watched all of his speeches
what is he training on and I said how to
[ __ ] the competition and which is above
our block then he goes I love that guy
please get a pic with him and tell him I
say thank you big sis they fire me the
[ __ ] up what's his name his name is
Christian so we have to do we have to
sum up and you have to send in like a
little go on video first and a serious
question Christian why is your pops here
and you're not [ __ ] are you Christian
the question becomes you know what are
we talking about here there's a very big
difference between going out to you know
Vegas for the weekend to hook up and go
to you know Towe every night versus
going out to networking events or even
going out socially as a proxy to the
networking that you need for example
booking agents and the people like I
know where people that book talent go
they're not where you and your friends
want to go they're two very different
places they're very different bars the
timing of when they hang out are
different if you're asking me should I
go out to you know you know you know a
club at one o'clock in the morning I'd
be like no that's you actually if you
you know that's you going out if you're
asking me should you go to the grill at
6 p.m. where you could be getting a
drink
just working on your phone and the
person next to you is booking people for
Broadway plays for real should you do
that yes there's a very clear difference
between work and play I'm going out to
play but maybe I'll run into business
versus respect so don't but networking
matters you know what's amazing about
the modern world this [ __ ] thing you
know going to the grill in 1984 and
hoping to find a talent agent or
whatever the [ __ ] is on the play
sucked because
because you sat there like a [ __ ]
jerk-off if nothing was happening you'd
go to the grill in 1984 you'd sit down
and you'd have to like look around and
like people are thinking you're trying
to hit on that gonna be convoluted the
fact that you can go there and just
start working on your phone while you
have a cocktail and if it plays it plays
but if not you basically just had a
two-hour meeting with yourself on your
work you could have done that at the
coffee shop you could have done that
laying in your bed you could have done
that right here that's [ __ ]
incredible
that is a palette that's the subtleties
that we don't give this credit for got
it that's big-time
I am myself I went to your um your talk
at this energy Global Forum yes
and I enjoyed it here and he was like
the most amazing thing ever I think you
know I follow you my whole family okay
now my go SAS thank you rob I work at
L'Oreal oh so cool it's so funny cuz I
was like oh my gosh that faders in my
building that's what I know about this
but you were amazing
Bailey super inspiring thank you so much
sausage thank you no worries no worries
thank you so much for saying hello run
[Music]
it's my garden ranch amount
Jamal Adams huh see ya
[Music]